guys this is what my Christmas tree
looks like this year it will be a family
affair for Britney Spears this Christmas
Eve et has exclusively learned that the
pop star will spend the holiday with her
kids Sean Preston and Jaden James
according to our source the boys will
then spend Christmas and the rest of the
week with their dad Kevin Federline his
attorney told e.t quote Kevin is always
happy that Britney can see the boys on
holidays if it falls in line with her
custodial time Kevin has no plans on
preventing her from doing so my
philosophy is just take each day at a
time
aside from Britt's kids she's also been
spending a lot of time with her
boyfriend Sam Ascari it's a lot of fun
the couple has been showing off all
kinds of PDA on her Instagram account
having fun in the Sun or getting their
fitness on et sat down with Sam earlier
this year the 25 year old actor opened
up about his relationship and their
plans for the future you guys have been
together almost three years now dude is
she the one you see marriage in the
future I mean absolutely this is
something that every couple should do
that's the whole point of a relationship
we're a family have your families met
yes yeah absolutely
what is your mom like you've sisters or
anything I have three sisters oh and
they're like yeah sounds bringing home
breeding freaking Spears to dinner yeah
it was one got a lot of times you know
we've been together for three years and
my sister's love her my family loves it
[Music]